this story made headlines and a local
ups delivery man named hector
he took the time to stop and brighten a
young boy's day take a look
hi drew we're excited to tell you about
a person who's made a very special
impact on our family during covid our
ups
delivery man hector we have a
four-year-old son who's been lonely and
cooped up inside
and gets very excited when he hears the
garbage man come by
the mailman but especially hector they
like kicker when he plays his music
and drive by my house i love playing
with trucks
one day when hector was delivering
packages langston stopped him and asked
him hey do you have any packages for me
hector had to give him the bad news and
said no i don't have any packages for
you but maybe tomorrow
maybe you'll get a package so the next
day langston heard him coming he ran
outside
shrieking and squealing in excitement
when hector pulled his truck up and came
up the stairs
and handed langston a box special for
him hey
give me a box full of toys and trucks
hector is my friend such an
amazing act of kindness on hector's part
to
be going through his busy day and still
be able to
see and notice our sun this little act
of kindness has just really gone a long
way and it keeps paying forward
thank you hector we love you
i just i love this so much
hector what made you hi hector how are
you
hi hi drew okay nice to meet you
you're so round
thank you so much for coming on the show
hector thank you for having me oh god we
are just talking right over each other i
am so sorry i'm gonna
ask you a question and then shut up hang
on check this out
what how did you notice langston like
what was it that made you clock him
well i had noticed langston
two weeks prior i saw him in his little
balcony i would say hi to him i would
wave at him i'd be like hey
or like hi or not you know because i'm
always busy running around
and uh i noticed him that one time when
i delivered to his neighbor
and uh as i go upstairs delivered to the
neighbor and then
i see him and then he looks at me and i
kind of noticed that he
noticed that i wasn't i was gonna give
him a package
and he just uh put his little arm and so
like
oh i won one too you know and uh that's
how i noticed them
well how did you know what would
how did you know what to get him
well i've had uh i've always
had toys or action figures for boys
you know because you know i've always
wanted a boy but you know we never had
one
i have two two daughters which is
awesome but
i told my wife i go you know what these
little toys that i've had i go i think i
know somebody
who would appreciate them more and i
guess enjoy them
oh i love that and i i'm in the two
girls club too and i had gotten these
little like
um stitched um needlepoint like football
helmet art
when in anticipation of having kids and
i
was like you know what the football
helmets and knit are still going up for
the girls
um and now i know that you love music
hector
as right yeah and um
you love a band called uh trivium
right
we did our research we heard you were a
fan of matt heffy
and we have a little surprise for you
take a look
hey hector it's matt hafey sayer and
guitar player of the multi-platinum
metal band trivium
drew told me you love blasting our music
while you're out delivering packages
community
so drew and i got together to put
together a special surprise for you
something a little bit like this thing
right here
gibson les paul in ebony this is the one
i use
yours is going to look pretty much like
this i've been using these things for a
couple of years i hope you love it as
much as i do
thanks for being a local community hero
my friend take it away drew
ah thank you so much oh hector
that's awesome i love you thank you drew
you know what
we just led by your example actually
you showed us what to do so thank you
thank you for teaching all of us what
kind of human to be
on this planet and uh gail king said
once and i heard it while i was pregnant
it gave me so much hope that our kids
will watch what we do and that will be a
huge part of
how they learn as kids to our parenting
and that gave me a lot of relief because
if we behave a certain way
then maybe our kids will pick up on it
so you're an example to your kids
and to us and thank you hector for being
a local hero
[Applause]
you're welcome thank you so much
you